yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
this is a second of my videos on the
Doctor Strange post-credit scenes in my
first video I discussed the mid-credits
scene from the film which teases a major
plot point from an upcoming Marvel phase
3 movie but in this video I'm going to
discuss the final post-credit scene that
appears right at the end of the movie
after all the credits have rolled just
so you're aware if you haven't seen
Doctor Strange yet there is a major
spoiler here for this movie and a future
movie so if you want to avoid that you
can check out my spoiler free review of
the film right here the scene opens with
a hooded figure walking into a workshop
where Jonathan Pangborn is working
Pangborn asks can I help you in the
hooded figure takes off his hood
revealing himself was more dough more
dough then replies I carried you to come
on tosh on a stretcher look at you now
Pangborn just to recap Pangborn is the
paralyzed man who dr. strange refused to
meet when he was in Euro surgeon as he
said he was untreatable however after
his own accident strange met with
Pangborn and learned that Pangborn had
discovered the power of magic at Kamata
and was using it to heal himself so he
could live his life without being
paralyzed as for Mordo he starts the
film as Doctor Strange is alive but by
the end of the movie is furious at
strange for using the eye of agamotto to
manipulate time and on top of that maldo
is also angry because he discovered that
the ancient one was using power from the
Dark Dimension to live longer than would
normally be possible for a human being
okay back to the post-credits scene
Pangborn senses something wrong about
more dos who reaches for a crowbar he
asked Mordo what he can do for him and
Mordor explains that he's been away for
several months and had a revelation that
the true purpose of a sorcerer is to
twist things out of their proper shape
stealing power perverting nature like
you
Pangborn replies that he stolen nothing
and that the power he holds is his own
Mordo retorts ominously that power has a
purpose Pangborn who now realizes that
Mordo has evil intent tries to attack
him with the crowbar but Mordo reaches
into pangborn's stomach and extracts the
yellow light causing Pangborn to
collapse his body now shaking as his
loss and magic he used to fight his
paralysis
Mordo then says he now understands what
is wrong with the world which is that
there are too many sorcerers the scene
ends and cuts to the words Doctor
Strange will return so this scene sets
of a possible Doctor Strange sequel and
a villainous
for more dough in the future MCU in the
comics Mordo studied with the ancient
one but had nefarious objectives and in
this final post-credits scene we get to
see his character tie up with his
traditional depiction as a villain in
the comics in a Doctor Strange sequel
some of the plot could revolve around
Mordo trying to rid the world of
sorcerers for example by taking their
powers like he did with Pangborn and
amassing them for himself getting ever
more powerful or what about this for a
potential sequel idea involving more
dough strange obviously succeeded in
angering Dormammu in the movie by
trapping him in a time loop and forcing
him to agree to end his assault on
strangers world and never come back well
strange also drew the wrath of Dormammu
in the strange tales comics when Doctor
Strange told Dormammu you must vow never
to invade the earth
and although Dormammu agreed he was
determined to get revenge on strange
then later in the comics Dormammu got
around that agreement by using Waldo as
a proxy telling Mordo I shall give you
power without limits so you may destroy
Doctor Strange so perhaps we'll see
Mordo ally with Dormammu in a similar
way in a Doctor Strange movie sequel or
maybe more dhoka combat before then for
instance in Avengers infinity war if he
gets recruited by Thanos to help him
recover the Infinity stones by the way I
also felt there was an interesting
unintended parallel between the
post-credits scene and Doctor Strange
and the mid-credits scene in the Green
Lantern movie where Mark Strong Sinestro
who's previously been on the Green
Lantern's side takes off his green ring
and puts on the yellow ring signalling
his transformation into a villain as
well as setting up a potential Green
Lantern sequel that never was so that
was the post-credits scene for Doctor
Strange why are you excited to see Mordo
turn to the dark side and fulfill his
comic-book villain role and what would
you like to see in a Doctor Strange
sequel if you haven't seen it yet you
can check out my breakdown of the
mid-credits scene here and do make sure
you're subscribed and you've got your
notifications turned on for flicks in
the city for a chance to win this
awesome Doctor Strange book which I'll
be giving away on my Easter Egg video
you might also like to check out my
Doctor Strange playlist which will
feature my Easter egg breakdown my movie
review WTF facts about the film and also
interviews with the cast
click either the links below to check
those out and if you like this I really
appreciate you hitting those like and
share buttons thanks for watching and
see you next time
you being a movie lovers